what's up guys bang bang KPMG came in
super hot to start the week KPMG
released a brand new white paper where
two authors said that Bitcoin is an ESG
friendly asset they didn't just make the
claim though what did they do they went
ahead and they took that ESG framework
environment social and governance and
they overlaid Bitcoin and they showed
exactly why Bitcoin fits into that
framework and checks all the boxes they
use cold hard facts to prove the point
when you go ahead and look at Bitcoin
many people say oh it uses too much
energy but as we know about 60 of all
energy use for Bitcoin comes from
renewable energy the reason why that's
important is the average percentage in
the American economy is closer to 18 for
an industry and so Bitcoin is three
times more likely to use renewable
energy than any other industry maybe we
should tell the other Industries to get
on bitcoin's level when it comes to all
the social potential benefits what we
see are things like Ukraine fundraising
or the ability to do remittances also
the ability to save and protect yourself
from inflation the KPMG team laid it out
perfectly this weekend that white paper
and then lastly when it comes to
governance oh boy if you're
decentralized that means that not one
person or organization controls the
network and therefore check mark you
have a better governance system because
more democratic it allows for more
participation than other systems that
exist and so KPMG putting their stamp of
approval on bitcoin from an ESG lens is
a major deal why there have been people
in the Bitcoin community that have been
talking about Bitcoin being an ESG asset
for a long time but the messenger
matters and kpmg's got way way way more
gravitational pull when they say it than
me or anyone else on the internet that
also then leads to another institution
microstrategy they went ahead and they
bought just over 14 million dollars of
Bitcoin that brings their Bitcoin
Holdings up to 152 800 Bitcoin
microstrategy also went ahead and issued
750 million dollars of potential shares
of their business to sell into the
market those proceeds very likely will
go to be converted into Bitcoin as they
sell shares raise cash buy Bitcoin it's
a whole game Michael sailor's been
playing it for a while and looks to
continue to want to double triple and
quadruple down on this strategy now
that's not the only thing that happened
of course will Clemente he pointed out
that we now have seen about a 30
reduction in the number of Bitcoin out
on exchanges since 2020. this is a big
deal because it signifies that many of
those people who took their Bitcoin off
of exchanges are likely to hold them for
the long term they can't just go on and
be emotional and click a button and sell
the Bitcoin tomorrow of course they've
got to then move it there's more
friction that signals that there's
likely to be longer term holders taking
over the market on top of that we now
see that the Bitcoin network has settled
870 million transactions we're not
talking dollar figures here individual
transactions on the Bitcoin Network all
time 870 million that means we're
closing in on the one big number one
billion when Bitcoin Hits 1 billion
transactions on the network it's gonna
be hard to continue to ignore it 870 is
pretty damn close and so if you're
continuing to ignore Bitcoin I don't
know how you even found this page this
video I don't know what you're doing but
870 million transactions is a big number
and then Dylan LeClaire he did a bunch
of Einstein math and he figured out that
the 10-day realized volatility of
Bitcoin that happens to be lower than
stocks or other assets why is that
important it's because Bitcoin
ultimately is a positive addition to a
portfolio if you go back and you look
and back test all the data putting a
little tiny bit of Bitcoin whether
that's half a percent one percent three
percent whatever that number is for you
into a portfolio tends to lead to an
increase in returns and because it has a
long history of being non-correlated
over long periods of time it tends to
provide a bunch of positive attributes
to a portfolio that you you can't get
with other assets now of course last but
not least is that there has been a ton
of talk around regulation and one of the
big stories that came out this past week
is that coinbase was asked by Regulators
to de-list everything but Bitcoin
whether that ended up happening or not
whether Regulators actually believe
everything else is a security or not and
whether a Court decides that the other
assets or Securities or not it doesn't
matter Bitcoin continues to be the asset
that everyone agrees is through the
regulatory threshold no one in a serious
manner no one in a position of power
seems to be saying Bitcoin is a security
and so it has regulatory Clarity which
means green light for institutions and
we're likely to see more and more of
them continue to come in now what hasn't
happened and I'm waiting for the update
in order to be able to share with All of
You Beautiful People is that bitcoin's
ETF the Bitcoin ETF spot ETF of
applications they have not been approved
yet and neither has gbtc been able to
convert into that spot Bitcoin ETF at
some point I don't know when I don't
know why but at some point I will be
able to deliver that awesome news to all
of you until then you have to keep
coming back here to watch these videos
my ugly face my beautiful voice and all
this great information hope that you
enjoy this video before I leave you I
got a big announcement this video was
brought to you by start engine the
biggest fortunes aren't made on Wall
Street they used to be made there but
now they're being made in private
markets consider Mike Walsh he put five
thousand dollars into Uber he's just a
regular dude turned it over 24 million
dollars such opportunities were once
held behind closed doors reserved for
those who had connections or vast
fortunes but not anymore start engine is
now going to tear down that glass
ceiling and make startup Investments
possible for you and me the company is
led by Howard marks the co-founder of
gaming giant Activision and they got 1.7
million users that have put in over 1.2
billion dollars of transactions on the
platform but the best part is the
platform not even backed by traditional
Venture capitalists it's back basically
by the community they've raised over 75
million dollars in crowdsource funding
to date go check them out at
startengine.com you can open up a start
engine account today and you can explore
live investing opportunities with
starting investing amounts as little as
a hundred dollars startengine.com go
check them out today